corporations shouldn't be allowed to
make these decisions on their own well
who should the people who eat the bread
this wouldn't happen if there were
centralized control over all these big
corporations are you suggesting a
communist form of government in Texas
I suppose I am
we have a viral video from somebody on
Tick Tock which is being shared
primarily by people on the right who
primarily find this person to be stupid
and her opinions worthless and that's
generally the way that it works with
these Tick Tock videos of course very
often the people are stupid and their
opinions are effectively worthless but
in this case I think that there's a
little bit more to be said about it so
let's first watch the clip all I can
ever think about is the fact that this
is
way that life is so to be the whole
working your life away just to have a
little bit of money a little bit of free
time to do things that you actually
enjoy it's such a waste of life and the
older generation will be the first to
call my generation lazy for saying
things like that not realizing that
they're just a bunch of capitalism and
they're brainwashed it's all nothing but
a capitalist hellscape that sucks the
life out of everyone I just hate all of
this I hate my ancestors I hate
everything that has happened throughout
history to get us to this point okay
well she uh gets a few things wrong here
just a few starting most importantly
with the very common misconception that
that happiness means having a lot of
free time to do what you want you can't
always get what you want if that was
true then virtually no one who ever
lived on earth up until the Industrial
Age at least was happy because free time
as she conceives it
is an extremely modern phenomenon we
think of free time as time without any
kind of work at all time dedicated to
total and complete Leisure that's free
time to us free time is sitting on the
couch for hours ordering food on
doordash relaxing in a very sedentary
position but historically unless you
were like a pharaoh or a Roman Emperor
or something that kind of leisure that
kind of free time was not on the menu
boom baby indeed this kind of free time
is an invention of our modern Western
capitalist system she wants free time
but she hates the thing that gives her
free time she's also wrong of course in
her hatred of our ancestors to hate your
own ancestors it's to be a branch that
curses the roots of the tree that you're
attached to you would not have your
existence at all without your ancestors
you would have neither the positives nor
the negatives you would have nothing and
be nothing and as it happens in the case
of this girl and all the rest of us we
can thank our ancestors for many more
positives than negatives as we already
established all the things that she has
and supposedly likes and wants more of
free time Leisure Etc she only has
because of the work Innovation and
sacrifice of the ancestors whose Graves
she now spits on I'll spit on your grave
grandma and most of the things that she
doesn't want and complains about work
hardship she would have that no matter
what choices her ancestors made given
that these are fundamental realities of
human existence but she's not wrong
about everything he's kidding right she
makes the point and it's a profound one
that many people in modern society are
effectively helpless they cannot do
anything for themselves they have no
skills they have no capacity to be
self-sufficient and even those who are
most skilled and most self-sufficient
still rely heavily on giant institutions
and corporations to provide them with so
many things and while this is all
happening we've also become more
isolated less Community focused we don't
even many of us know our neighbors who
live next door the social experience has
migrated online into our phones behind
the screen where we can connect with
people but that connection is always
limited by the technology that
facilitates it and nothing feels exactly
real Hello I'm here oh
hi she seems to have noticed all of this
and it's good that she's noticed it but
the next step for anyone who notices
this problem is to do something about it
you can develop skills you can learn to
to care for yourself to a great extent
you can even form families and
communities all of this is possible
modern society offers a certain way to
live a way that's easy but empty and we
can take it up on that offer or not you
don't have to be miserable or alone or
helpless that's not a requirement it's
an item on the menu the others just take
discipline and effort which is a price
that many people including this girl at
this point don't want to pay and that is
why she is still ultimately
Unfortunately today canceled you know a
company's looking out for you when they
actually upgrade your service and they
don't charge you for it pure talk just
added data to every new and existing
plan they're also including a mobile
hotspot with each new plan as well with
no price increase whatsoever if you've
considered pure talk before but you
haven't made the switch you need to take
a look again for just twenty dollars a
month you'll get unlimited talk text and
now fifty percent more 5G data plus a
mobile hotspot I love pure talk not only
do they offer great services but they
also happen to be veteran owned and they
only hire the best United states-based
customer service team available remember
you vote with how you spend your money
so stop supporting woke wireless
companies that don't support you when
you go to puretalk.com Walsh you'll save
an additional 50 off your first month
because they actually value you that's
puretalk.com Walsh puretalk Wireless for
Americans by Americans it's sick and
twisted that I have to work just to
survive just to live my life for basic
necessities like I don't want to work
until the day I die just to eat and
sleep basic human Necessities it
shouldn't be controversially
Free Housing free health care shouldn't
be a pipe dream and I know a lot of
people are going to be like oh you
should be doing this or that no like
what if I don't want to be rich what if
I want to achieve
I still have to work till the day die
just to live just to survive and I want
to be told that I'm ungrateful that
I should be happy to have a job where
it's taking up 40 hours of my week 40
hours of my week people are complain
about a 40 hourly job they blow my mind
you know how you know how lucky you are
I know he said I don't I don't be told
that I should be grateful well you
should be grateful you brat I can't even
like conceive of only doing 40 hours of
work in a week
okay so we have again
a young man who appears to be well fed
appears to be living in some kind of
comfortable shelter presumably a house
or an apartment and who is obviously
blessed with any number of luxuries like
a phone internet connection we can
assume copious amounts of hair products
he has all of this and yet doesn't
believe that work should be a
requirement to maintain it it's sick and
twisted that he should have to work just
to live let alone to afford his hair
conditioner as I've often said in
response to these kinds of disturbingly
common complaints from his generation
bitching about the fact that you have to
work is like bitching about the fact
that you have to breathe you might as
well make a video whining like yeah
you're telling me I have to breathe
every second of the day just to live
exhale inhale exhale inhale all the time
just to live what if I don't want to
breathe what if I want to live at the
bottom of the ocean like a starfish
they're doing absolutely nothing longer
than anyone else Patrick this trophy for
you why should breathing be a
requirement this is sick and twisted
it'd be a lot easier if we didn't have
to do any of that it'd be easier if we
could exist as Immortal indestructible
Supermen who need nothing and want
nothing and can do anything without
expending any any energy at all that
would be nice but that is not how things
are or will ever be it doesn't work that
way we've talked about Mr hair and uh
you know and and why he cannot have what
he wants he cannot he cannot have the
sort of existence that he feels entitled
to but let's let's not allow that to
distract us from a more important Point
as a young man you shouldn't want to not
work you shouldn't want to Coast through
life he says he doesn't want to achieve
anything and in that lack of ambition
and that mentality he is joined
unfortunately by many in his generation
but it is a deeply depraved mentality it
is not natural it is not normal or at
least it shouldn't be as a young man you
should have big dreams and goals you
should have designs on like Conquering
the world you you may lack wisdom and
experience but you should not lack for
ambition I mean that's the one thing you
should not lack for we got an entire
generation addicted to phone owns
practically from birth and as a result
we destroyed for many of them any hope
that they that they might become
successful and along with that we
destroyed civilization as well but the
good news is the aliens are just going
to vaporize us anyway so in the meantime
however Mr hair is canceled well have
you ever worked with dreads before
that's what you do in the eyes and we
finish it